[Music]
no let's just sit on the dock
no this is not okay
you guys can go through a lot
emotionally and then you bring it back
to the complete reset of
game on would you ladies like me snacks
or anything like that
that's a good snack tonight we have
rigatoni bolognese
you got regular tony and nolan
guess what i'm your chew stew now you
can't be too bougie
this is how you do it oh my god
did you notice how nice he is uh yeah oh
hi
are you ready for this wedding day my
god
we got married good job so
thankful look at this rainbow
dave you've got a little soft spot for
anyone we might be competing for the
same girl
last night was like okay i don't know
you
[Music]
love your first sight love it first
night boat romances
they're dangerous i just chased white
wine
this is what happens when i'm single the
lazy susan is being ridden
hard
[Music]
come on
keep the line out of the water please to
lead people
is to invest in them thanks so much i
love that it's up to you
when it comes to like decisions that
affect like a lot of people
i can just don't like it right now i'm
pissed off with you
i don't care i'm like leaving hey mom
i'm quitting
this boat that's an incident report
malia i'm not a chief officer
i don't give a [ __ ] you should have come
to me that he was hurt
his blood pressure is really high he has
chest pains he needs to go to the
hospital
this is going to pass i promise
if we're not challenged then we won't
grow whoa what's going on there
if you stop it's on me everybody's being
so
[ __ ] dramatic stop the
[ __ ] boys
yes
you